what we're going to do in this video is
use a graphing calculator to answer some
questions dealing with binomial random
variables and this is useful because if
you're taking the AP stats the Advanced
Placement statistics test you are
allowed to use a graphing calculator and
so this could actually save you
significant time so it says here I have
a 0.35 probability of making a free
throw what is the probability of making
four out of seven free throws well this
is a classic binomial random variable
question if we said the binomial random
variable random variable X is equal to
number of made free throws from seven I
could say seven trials or seven shots
seven trials with the probability of
success is equal to 0.35 for each free
throw so really this question amounts to
what is the probability that my binomial
random variable X is equal to four now
what we're going to see is we can use a
function on our ti-84 not named binome C
or binompdf I should say binome PDF
which is short for binomial probability
distribution function and what you're
going to want to do here is use three
arguments so the first one is the number
of trials so in this case it is seven
and if you're doing it on the free
response section of the AP test you
should make it very clear that that
right over there is your n that's like
the graders will actually look for that
to make sure that you're not just you
know guessing what goes where so you
would say that is my n and then you
would say your probability 0.35 and once
again if you're taking the test you
should mark that that is your P and then
last but not least what is the
probability that a binomial variable
when you're taking seven trials with the
probability of success of each of them
being 0.35 that you have exactly four
successes so now let's get our
calculator out and actually do that all
right so now we have our graphing
calculator out so there's a couple of
ways to input this you could just type
it into
correctly that could take time you could
do second and this little blue
distribution here so there you have it
in order to get to the function you
could either scroll down or you could
scroll up to get to the bottom of the
list and you see it right over here
binompdf
you could do alpha a to go there really
fast or you could just scroll up here
click enter and then you have you at the
number of trials that you want to deal
with well we're gonna take seven trials
the probability of success in each trial
is 0.35 and then my x value well i want
to find the probability that my binomial
random variable is equal to 4 for
successes out of the trials and now let
me go to paste and this is actually
going to type in exactly what we had
before notice this is the exact same
thing so I have seven trials P is equal
to 0.35 and I wanna know the probability
of having exactly four successes and
then I just click enter and I get there
you go 0.14 so this is equal to
approximately 0.14 now based on these
the same binomial random variable if
we're then asked what is the probability
of making less than five free throws so
we could say this is the probability
that X is less than five or we could say
this is the probability that X is less
than or equal to four and the reason why
I write it this way is because using it
this way you can now use the binomial
cumulative distribution function on my
calculator so if I just type in binome
and once again I'm going to take seven
or binome CDF I should say cumulative
distribution function and I'm gonna take
seven trials and the probability of
success in each trial is 0.35 and now
when I type in four here it doesn't mean
what is the probability that I make
exactly four free-throws it is the
probability that I make zero one two
three or four free-throws so all of the
possible outcomes of my binomial random
variable up to
including this value right over here so
let me get that let me get my calculator
back so once again I can go to the
second distribution I'll scroll up to go
to the bottom of list and here you see
it binomial cumulative distribution
function so let me go there click enter
and once again seven trials my P is 0.35
and my x value is four but now this is
going to be giving me the probability
that I that my binomial random variable
equals four this is going to give me the
probability that I get any value up to
and including four so this should be a
higher probability and there you have it
it is zero approximately zero point nine
four so this is approximately zero point
nine four so hopefully you found that
helpful these calculators can be very
useful especially on something like an
AP stats exam